bonjour hugo tous et merci d'être dans
son caddie ce matin 1er adjoint au maire
du diamant gilbert eustache vous venez
vous tous et vous ainsi que suzanne
rancio hilaire louis-alexandre aussi
maire-adjoint de remettre vos
délégations maire jean-claude d'azur et
alexandre tués sont eux aussi dans la
contestation vous avez adressé un
courrier au maire pour lui expliquer
votre démarche eu beau pousser les rats
sont identifiés en train de quitter le
navire parce que la municipalité est en
difficulté dans ses finances on le
rappelle déficit de 2 millions d'euros
oui alors je tiens à rectifier nous ne
quittons pas le navire
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
aujourd'hui nous ne contestons pas mais
nous dénonçons un fonctionnement qui est
non démocratiques depuis décembre 2015
de la part du maire et si la raison pour
laquelle nous avons remis nos
délégations
il faudrait que qu'aujourd'hui au
diamant la politique on retrouve ses
lettres de noblesse avec notamment tout
son éthique
les vins toutes ces valeurs donc c'est
ce que nous nous faisons des fiances
quand même
ce n'est pas un geste de défense vous
savez lorsque vous avez cinq élus qui
vont mettre quand même leurs délégations
ce n'est pas rien ce n'est pas rien ce
n'est pas deux sèvres dans tester une
méthode nous nous contestons nous
dénonçons une méthode et un
fonctionnement
c'est le déficit dans le budget cette
pression désormais exercées par la
chambre régionale des comptes qui est
dur à supporter pour vous qui venait de
remettre la délégation alors là l'avis
de la chambre régionale des comptes qui
effectivement nous nous souligne déficit
de 2 millions d'euros
il faut savoir que le
les alertes parce que nous sommes la
peau à les hanter le maire nous sommes
là pour alerter la population
il ne s'agit pas de remettre une
délégation parce qu'il y a déficit
ça fait un moment depuis pratiquement un
an que nous dénonçons un fonctionnement
d'une mise à l'écart
tout simplement parce que gilbert rozon
tâche a senti cette pression de la
chambre régionale des comptes cette
pression des chiffriers dans cette
tourmente il a voulu peut-être contrôler
davantage les choses non comme je
voulais dit ça ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
ça fait pratiquement un an qu on le
martèle s'y voit qu'on ne l'a pas dit
omidyar nous nous sommes restés en petit
petit comité en petits groupes
chaque bureaux municipaux de chaque
bureau municipal nous dénoncions un
certain nombre de faits un certain
nombre de dysfonctionnements nous ne
l'avons pas rendu public mais maintenant
un moment donné qu'en prenant nous on ne
nous écoute pas forcément ce qu'on fait
si nous ne sommes pas en mesure de faire
dépôt des propositions nous remettons
une délégation ça ne nous intéresse pas
de toucher des indemnités et puis d'être
là comme des élus fantoches plus
personnellement avec vous tous et vous
avez les clés de la mairie en étant
premier adjoint en est en charge des
finances du budget délégation signature
l'échec de gilbert eustache
c'est aussi un peu le vôtre aussi alors
là dessus j'ai pas de jets pas de souci
nous avons bien fonctionné pendant une
mandature de 2008 à 2010 recense que
vous travaillez en sang ça fait huit ans
que nous travaillons ensemble jeu je
revois et j'entends gilbert à l'époque
qui disaient il suffit qu'on se regarde
pour qu'on se comprenne et c'est
toujours le cas
c'est toujours le cas maintenant
qu'est-ce qui est ce que c'est parce
qu'est ce qui a changé ce qui a changé
c'est décembre 2015
et voilà c'est tout donc s'être senti
trahi par gilbert eustache lorsqu'il a
choisi d'allier de se rapprocher dansant
pour une martinique nouvelle vous qui
étiez beaucoup plus proche de claude
vise alors trail chaque homme à la la
libre opinion que qu'il le fasse c'est
pas ça le problème
le poème s'il peut changer s'il veut 6 6
6 voix je me rappelle que lors d'une
interview il a dit on ne m'a rien
proposé de l'autre côté ça m'a quand
même choqué mais maintenant c'est que
c'est pas ça le problème le problème
c'est que lorsqu'on sort des élections
de la ctm qu'on puisse redevenir
dans un système de fonctionnement normal
son job visiblement très bien
aujourd'hui les élus qui dénoncent qui
alerte comme par hasard ce sont ceux qui
ont suivi le grand ensemble est pour bat
p ierre chanson on se pose des questions
ça neutre a dit qu il pas non plus une
forme d'impatience de votre part alors
ce n'est pas de l'impatience moi ce qui
m'intéresse aujourd'hui le père ce qui
m'intéresse aujourd'hui nous avons un
déficit de 2 millions d'euros
quand serons-nous pour résorber ce
déficit et il ya une population qui nous
regarde moi le l'avenir politique de 2 x
ou y ne m'intéresse pas aujourd'hui ce
qui m'intéresse c'est sortir cette ville
de ce gouffre financier en termes de
stratégie puisque vous dénoncer la façon
de faire de gilbert eustache vous
dénoncer ce qui se passe dans les
finances de la ville du diamant vous
auriez pu faire les choses beaucoup plus
rapidement on se rappelle tout est
actuel vous êtes a soutenu lors de
l'examen du compte administratif vendée
il est contre vous avez voté contre
vous êtes revenu quelque part aux pieds
de jon on va dire ça comme ça au mois de
mai dernier en votant finalement le
budget et qu'est-ce qui nous a répondu
vous étiez obligés de le faire
vous pensez que c'est une façon de
rétablir les choses
qu'est ce qui va se passer maintenant à
tous et va faire quoi lui et les autres
personnes qui viennent de remettre leurs
délégations vous avez vous ghannouchi
l'ancien lamour l'ancien logo édition
pensée nous allons continuer de
travailler
moi ce que je pense très sincèrement
aujourd'hui pour le diamant non papou
yvette galot non pas pour hugo tout ceni
pour le maire ce qui convient de faire
aujourd'hui c'est de rassembler les
bonnes volontés les compétences et les
intelligences de ceux de cette équipe
municipale
quel que soit le bord politique pour
sortir de ce gouffre celles ci sont plus
recensé quelque part vous êtes il vous
êtes art
en même temps je ne suis pas une je ne
suis pas entre nous travaillons c'est
tout et nous voulons travailler et c'est
pour cela que nous ne démissionnerait
pas nous ne démissionnons pas et ici
même je me rappelle que le maire en
aparté avait sorti quelques jeux fait un
rappel comme historique
lorsqu'il avait dit quand j'étais le
premier adjoint de sir georges et j'ai
démissionné
je tiens à rétablir le
la vérité il est resté pendant des
années en litige avec ses joueurs il n'a
pas démissionné il a démissionné
quelques mois avant les élections de
donc soyons sérieux nous sommes là pour
travailler nous sommes une équipe nous
avons des compétences nous avons des
intelligences et il faut qu'on se mette
au travail et nous sommes en octobre
2016 les prochaines échéances il en
parle c'est 2020 ce sera long comment ça
va se passer
par exemple vous avez annoncé au maire
gilbert eustache que le 11
mardi prochain vous ne pourriez pas être
en martinique viennent quand même
fiction conseil municipal alors comment
vous le prenez ça je préfère en toute
intelligence dire que ce n'est qu'une
pure coïncidence
parce qu'effectivement il ya deux
semaines johnny corriger les noms mais
vous savez je suis là peau pour pour
l'apaisement
donc effectivement j'aurais pu dire que
c'est que cette carte de l'apaisement
également gilbert eustache les camps
après ce que vous venez de lui faire on
vient de répondre un fonctionnement on
ne lui a rien fait non répond un
fonctionnement soyons sérieux
lorsque lorsque vous êtes mettez vous à
ma place en tant que premier adjoint
lorsque vous n'êtes convient aucune
réunion concernant les finances que ça
soit sur en sous préfecture que ça soit
avec les banques
que ça soit avec les services de l'état
quand lorsque le meilleur pas
effectivement et que je me fie remplacé
par quelqu'un d'autre alors que je suis
en martinique que comme à lille 1-4 par
gilbert eustache vous dira qu'il vous
amis vous amis qui vous a mis sur les
rails qu'il est venu vous choisir très
tôt très jeune qui vous a confié les la
porte de l'espace sud vos amis première
adjointe et les clés de son bureau
oh oui alors là encore j'ai entendu ça
aussi les clés de son boulet dessus et
vous jouez le jeu voilà vous raconter
l'histoire de ces cycles et de bureaux
lorsque je suis arrivé en 2008 avec
gilbert eustache avec toute son équipe
parce qu'il n'est pas venu me chercher
seulement nous nous formons une équipe
alors anciennement la première adjointe
en place à vingt bureaux et lorsqu'on
est arrivé au pouvoir il y avait un
certain nombre d'agents qui n'avaient
pas de bio j'ai dit très clairement je
n'ai pas besoin de bureaux et le bureau
du premier adjoint de la première
adjointe de l'époque on la scinder en
deux pour en faire 2 de bureaux pour les
agents et c'est dans ces conditions que
gilbert effectivement m'a dit bon mais
tu n'as qu'à prendre mon bios vous
travaillez tious à gilbert non mais je
n'ai pas de problème personnel avec
gilles b alors attention actionnement on
n'avait pas l'intention de démissionner
ce que vous attendez de lui qu'il se
retire lui puisque manifestement il aura
beaucoup de difficultés à fonctionner au
cours des deux prochaines années des
trois prochaines années nous n'avons pas
de problèmes au travail et nous le
groupe jeudi entre guillemets constitué
puisqu'il en a fait un groupe et c'est
vrai que c'est la raison pour laquelle
un moment donné ça et qu'on était une
énième alerte lorsque nous avons fait un
article de leurs fonds dans le fonds
santé au lendemain du budget on nous
avons dit que nous étions une majorité
de circonstance
s'ils voient qu'il ne l'a pas apprécié
mais quelque part il a fait en sorte que
ces élus là bas soit regroupé parce que
nous sommes là encore une fois pour
sortir ce diamant de ce gouffre et à mon
avis l'une des possibilités d'une de
solutions kg et du fer pour ce budget
c'est de dire ben là le lait
diamantinoise sont en souffrance
aujourd'hui nous avons des impôts est
énorme mais déposons nous toutes nos nos
indemnités
nous déposons nos indemnités puis
faisant cette économie à trois secondes
qui sera le futur leader de l'opposition
hugo tous et charles joseph angélique ou
yvette galot il n'y aura pas de leaders
de l'opposition il y aura un
regroupement et ça c'est déjà fait 1 au
diamant avec le grand rassemblement
merci d'avoir été ce matin avec nos une
goutte ou se rappelle que vous êtes
maire adjoint à la ville du diamant cité
5 à 10